[Music]
story in five words Mike's new book
puzzles me all right first question I
have to ask you Mike never give an inch
who is this who are you talking about
like never give an inch to whom any bad
guys any bad guys right how's that
that's pretty good yeah so you're
talking about are you talking about
other countries or like I'm always Torn
Between the talking about Good and Evil
and then also this like I started
reading about uh what do you call it
cognitive empathy trying to be able to
understand the Enemy by just like what
what are their interests it's like no
but if you do that people will say
you're you're uh sympathizing yeah it's
it's a pretty nasty world out there you
gotta you gotta be pretty strong and
yeah we did that okay yeah what would
you what's your feeling these days about
Ukraine oh let me let me rephrase that
are we in a war with Russia and Ukraine
is just basically our our instrument no
I I don't think so I think Putin may
think that we are but I don't think
that's the case really yeah
what do you think we are well I kind of
feel that way because it's been that
we've been running hot and cold with
them for so long but he did invade yeah
so I mean killing lots of little kids
yeah exactly exactly what did you make
of zielinski thanking uh was it what do
you think JP Morgan Goldman Sachs uh
BlackRock that was weird that's weird
yeah no that's weird look I spent some I
spent some time with zelinsky I'm
surprised he's pretty bold I give him
credit for that lots of problems in
Ukraine lots of corruption but yeah uh
but you know they're fighting there's no
doubt about that yeah that's the thing
that's that you know they are fighting
for their country so it's like all that
other stuff kind of goes away but there
is a bit of thing and we do have to
follow the money you know when you're
when it's going to Ukraine you watch
every Buck yeah because it'll end up in
Hunter's hot tub
and then you're gonna have to disinfect
it
what are you looking at I'm just looking
at you I know I know do you miss Trump
what was it like working with him
because I I
I you know I talk to him off and on yeah
and I I've always got the sense of like
keeping like it's always good to be on a
friendly basis with him but don't get
too close because because you don't want
to be the target of like anger is there
what was it like do you see the pictures
of me after those four years
I think that answers your question how
did you lose your weight uh stop dating
everything I love but will you okay let
me ask you this yeah
that's how it goes down yeah yeah that's
kind of it I don't know
I still feel it just how can you get up
in the morning that's the heart okay so
you know then that if you so you're
basically did you do kind of an Atkins
diet
I just stopped eating I don't know I
seriously I literally literally no bread
no pasta I just that's what I ate
chicken vegetables he didn't give an
inch yeah no uh no what's that stuff
called that everybody's doing a zempo
azenko ozempic everybody's taking it no
but if I can find a shortcut sign me up
that's what I'm saying
absolutely diabetics can't get the drug
because all everybody in Hollywood's
popping it yeah you know the needle so
you're not popping it it's a needle yeah
I don't read the stories well it's uh he
asked him a question about North Korea
North Korea yes no go for the weight
loss thing I know the answer to that one
yeah when you were going through it it
turned out pretty cool I mean I was like
going this is crazy and then it works
out I mean how were you when you were
watching that happen yeah it was pretty
cool yeah my first trip especially uh
was a clandestine trip I was a CI
director nobody knew I was there it's
the only thing that didn't leak in four
years in Washington
yeah it was and then you're with this
guy he's pretty evil he's like he's a
little guy yeah yeah kind of sweaty yeah
kind of sweaty yeah wow I think him and
I would get along
am I taller than him
no just say it no yes
oh don't make phone depends but make fun
of gutfeld's height
which I have a question actually what
advice do you have for men like Greg who
don't have an inch to give
laughs
we're gonna miss her I'm gonna miss her
we're gonna miss her I love that joke
but you won't be back
exactly I assume you're not going to
answer that
are you ready for president
you know come on that's a yes yeah
that's a yes what we're thinking about
it so uh and I'm gonna give out three
names you tell me which one killed JFK
okay all right all right you go all
right Sammy Davis Jr uh very unlikely
all right uh let's go with Phyllis
Diller
no no comment
I gotta make it expect CIA I think
Phyllis Diller I'm going
to said the aliens did it and it would
have blown my brain that was that guy it
was a guy with it yeah oh sure
the black alien
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else